you dont celui-ci est aujourd'hui se
retrouvent sur et rires je tout
fraîchement sorti fin frais en est
sortie en 2012 mais bon c'est encore
frais je propose de cliquer sur play en
le chargement pas très beau et
d'atterrir dans de l'eau voilà et danton
et bébé pleurer voilà rien de plus
rassurant vous l'aurez funès un petit
jeu doha voilà on n'est pas sûr a dit
bout face à des bulls est devenu ça
c'est un peu dangereux alors la
situation et manque du personnel dans la
partie ii b laisse-moi ridley ce mot
lire et pourquoi mais la feuille pencher
comme ça c'est comme ça qu'on fait que
tout je dois investir les lieux à propos
des plus tard des travailleurs disparus
mystique et fathers tout à aywaille et
puis on avance
qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est du tag
et revoir tiger ok ayel super lourd
alors on y va on doit aller là dedans je
suis pro doit trouver des gens qui ont
disparu et où une belle note
barrette de lire mais tu les fruits
comme ça issus à aux théories [ __ ] ça
me stresse à mort ce genre de bruit à la
con là assez horrible hors d'elle et du
coup on peut plus on peut plus on peut
plus lire la note
dépêche-toi dépêche-toi la france au
moyen des teintes cette lumière snow
kids se jouera sur un débat où on y va
on y va on y va
tac machin auxquels elle a fait un coup
à la voile à y glisser cool & bike & run
le tuto allez allez allez allez nous le
bouton et le bouton il est là ta gueule
c'est quoi ça si les travailleurs
disparus
le ciel ce mois là je les laisse
disparaître encore plus quoi y avait pas
moyen ok bah c'est parti alors c'est
bien et il n'y a pas une liste des
objectifs à 6 voilà cinq clés huit chats
mais aussi des bas mais sûr c'est
trouver des humains en voie de
disparition qui sont en train de décéder
le mec motivé tu seras tu aime les chats
au passage on sait jamais à bas la chute
de la zone y avait le cas chez nous
contre est vite fait et ça fait
longtemps qu'on avait fait un petit jeu
de renvoyer
ses réflexes et un baiser mais tu crois
que nous ferons quoi mon gars là donc on
sent pas ton haleine c'est que tu es
loin nous voilà il doit avoir une
haleine ac ou fin ce monsieur écoutez je
trace c'est quoi ça c'est des pics jeu
tag je tacle un bordel au mec c'est quoi
ses miaulements toujours tuer les rats
donc je vais mettre une flèche ici qui
va faire ça voilà tous les champs forme
de flash bien sûr voilà
j'adore faire ça il nous donne une bombe
attaque vous doutez bien qu'on va pas
l'utiliser comme une goutte à goutte
avec bayrou c'est mon arme je prends sa
peau il n'a jamais su que ça envoie du
poivre enfin du gaz lacrymogène plus tôt
puisque du poivre c'est mignon ah non il
est tout prêt à temps ça c'est pas un
chat ça voir ça un chat qui ressemble
beaucoup à lima j'examine ok j'ai une
clé su faire au [ __ ] mais on dirait
des bo c'est sacha ces éléments ou
attendent que je leur en a je me suis
mon t-shirt et aucun point même master
cas et requerrait une fois une clé pour
activer sa auquel aliens notes ou alors
apparemment il faisait des des
expériences sur des sujets et les chiens
pourraient déchets liquides explique ça
c'était les chats des sujets peut-être
donc je vais mettre une flèche pour dire
que je venais de dollars voilà on y
pense un tant sois frais très sérieux
hein il à côté soit possible il est où
à terme ce qui est tu vas à [ __ ] c'est
quoi ça dans les poches et booste plus
match que j'avais pu bordel les
toilettes
je suis caché ta gueule le chat ta
gueule tu vas nous faire opérer tu te
tais tu auras des croquettes temps du
roi et canapa du schéma droit de la
qualité mais tais-toi l'hôpital veut pas
bouffer ses seuls chez eux au monde qui
veut pas bouffer aa je suis choqué je
suis d'ailleurs quoi ça sert
c'est bon il est passé il a valu conduit
hier pour la peine je vais dessiner un
easy swap avec mon gars voilà je t'aime
il habite
ce manque de respect à ce pont ces voies
de roulement se venger faire gaffe parce
que mon style de celui qu amy s'est on
est nous a vus ah [ __ ] ils sont
plusieurs
tu pas au jeu je suis importe quoi c
c'est un [ __ ] de labyrinthes c'est
scandaleux on voit jamais finir ce jeu
je vais dire que je suis passé par là
lucas ici tu auras dessiner un simple
point
voilà alors générateur trois axes est
déniée j'aimerais attend un accès daigné
s que l'éventuelle je peux accéder à une
salle de générateurs gestion de noms
impossibles quoi nous fait un bon gros
doigts et comprend pourquoi il ya tout
le temps des bruits d'haleine il est pas
là arrêté un moment il faut que trouve
quoi encore non c'est pas ça ça va je
suis faux cachets entend les cris de
code barre toi bartois barre toi y'a pas
un petit chat là où une clé à bahia
je crois qu'ils aiment bien les deux oui
on a une petite j'ai 2 kgs carrelage et
2 c'est la porte du narrateur et on
était à [ __ ] je pouvais monter là où
il ya un shaq est coincé dans cette
salle alors je suis totalement perdue
c'est là que à une entité à tort vu
quelqu'un d'autre il a dans un coin en
position fait de a à a
on est au bordel j'ai aucune idée de
tout il faut vraiment utile cette bombe
la rue de faire des beats avec part tout
allait bien heureusement qu'il est
sacrément con ce monstre hommes sinon
c'est complètement geek est allé saluer
regarder ces expériences j'avais pas vu
où ils les ont mis dans des tubes avec
de l'eau de l'aude aquaboulevard de
l'eau vraiment pleine de microbes
c'est bien de pleurer mais montre toi
line cartes jeux l'aiea [ __ ] j'ai fait
un point voyez on a bien fait de faire
un point ces deux là dont on venait donc
de logiquement les trucs sont à gauche
alors il faut établir une carte des
lieux suis jamais aux toilettes ici il
ya peut-être un chat ici on s'est envoyé
une carte là j'ai un jeu baiser si la
rive-sud baiser s'il arrive que tu fais
et je suis baiser voilà en effet six y
tient alors là on a toutes les cartes
des portes j'ai mis du lait il faut
qu'on retrouve la salle il y avait les
trois portes là aux questions de par la
sas était une tentative lucas oil à la
hoya il ya eu d'importants quoi c'est
une tentative à l'embargo lui c'est
vraiment le monde ce que tu crains le
moins au monde quad de tous les jeux
deux ans qu'on a fait c'est pour ceux
plus nul on s'en bat les steaks de lui à
la nourrir des lexiques ses petites
jambes dégueulasse corps ici avait un
chat hockey et je pense savoir où il est
il nous faut faire du parcours il est là
il est faible et malade juste là sur le
et qu'est ce qu'il fout là où elle
attend une grille carrément le fantasme
du développeur qui veut nous faire de
perche y ait quoi regarder les lionceaux
tes baisers
c'est totalement baiser agressé de venir
mais oui il manque une ligne de code
pour qu'il soit bolamba ici c'est fait
lucas bon ça c'est une croix mais enfin
on n'en fait pas un papillon 120 x mais
c'est quand même beau generator sba
voilà c'est par là ma [ __ ] mais si
j'étais un peu les panneaux au pôle à
quoi alors j'appuie sur eux et
générateurs à désactiver c'est parfait
c'est tout ce qu'on voulait monsieur
générateur 2-2 active à lancieux
générateur 3d active s'est ouvert une
porte
et ben voilà on n'a plus rien à faire
ici donc on fait un rond voilà face à un
papillon encore bon j'ai dû passer la
salle on élit c'est tout droit là bas
j'ai peur là au croisement comme ça
faisait ces fourbes j'ai envie de
respecter les priorités à droite mais
j'ai un peu peur si je laisse la
priorité va bouffer la tête en fait en
échange voilà c'est là où il ya ces
[ __ ] de l'homme qui sont allés mais
quand j'étais à l'aise générateur et là
où la porte est ouverte aux mondiaux on
tombe sur quoi ah là là il ya
d'expérience ou de l'agglo qui sont
passés ici c'est quoi examiner ouais à
tempted to these boys like supporter
il se passe quoi critique al mal
fonction critique aux mondiaux j'ai
libéré tous les monstres mais il ya le
petit comté qui va m'aider
les [ __ ] me largue là dedans à moins
que quelqu'un tag avant moi y at il un
autre survivant à berne en fait soit
c'est direction la fin du jeu là mais du
coup j'ai abandonné 6 chabada macias
mois les modes je m'en fous face et des
feuilles a4 on s'en fou qu'elle brûle
non c'est pas fini regarder on est
largué juste là je suis les flèches à un
moment on va suivre les flèches pas
l'estac
j'ai la master key le petit je prends
mes jambes à mon cou et je me rendrai
ex-idole loket voilà elle apporte de
l'excitation et un hockey et on peut
s'exciter
alors si on voit des beats et qu'on est
sur la bonne voie la habite là du oui en
effet c'est par là je te vois pas tu es
noir et je suis dans le noir bordel mais
juste la [ __ ] j'avais dessiné une [ __ ]
il était juste au bout de la [ __ ] quoi
mais non c'est pas par là mouillage
tourner au début tu ne sais pas du tout
par là au nom on est choqué eh ben on
l'a bien dans les fesses finalement j'ai
décidé d étudier c'est pas pour rien
vous voyez ce que je veux dire
excellence a blagué vraiment et par là
c'est en bas mais oui c'est en bas
atteint fin juste que je suive les
flammes et regarder mais qu'elle s'était
reste l' excite voilà excite vous vous
êtes amphi du lac erie avec une station
est plus travaillé de peines et c'est la
france attendait si on fait le bilan on
a trouvé huit notes sur 8 on a sauvé
deux chats sur huit soit plus important
bah si les feuilles a4 c'est les notes
voilà j'en suis fière d'en céder au
sourire il est chez nous à +6 et casey
babineau koné du record du monde de
vitesse en là on l'a pas écouté je suis
un peu je pensais que les objectifs ont
été obligés de remplir en fait pas du
tout quoi sert tu peux avoir c'est rond
notre héros chat rien de juste les trois
générateurs de 10 et active
et puis tu peux te barrer comme un lâche
quoi le jeu de l'égoïsme finalement pu
l'appeler mais ça vaut rien et surtout
le monde pis
[Musique]